Often, in linear
optimization problems,
we've estimated the data
we're using in the problem,
but it's subject to change.
Understanding how the solution
changes when the data changes
is called sensitivity analysis.
One way that the
data could change
is through marketing decisions.
Suppose that American
Airlines' management
is trying to figure
out whether or not
it would be beneficial to
invest in marketing its fares.
They forecast that
the marketing effort
is likely to attract one more
unit of demand, of each type,
for every $200 spent.
So for the discount fare,
the marketing cost per unit
is $200, and for
the regular fare,
the marketing cost
per unit is also $200.
We want to know how
much this will increase
our marginal revenue
for each type of fare.
This graph shows our current
feasible space and optimal
solution.
What would happen if we
increased the marketing
for discount fares?
The demand for discount
fares would increase.
But since we're not even meeting
the current demand for discount
fares with the
optimal solution, this
doesn't give us
any extra revenue.
So we shouldn't add any
marketing for discount fares.
Actually, American Airlines
could decrease their budget
to market discount fares, and
even if the demand decreases,
it wouldn't change our revenue.
The demand could go
all the way down to 66
without affecting our decisions.
In sensitivity
analysis like this,
we're often concerned with the
shadow price of a constraint.
For a discount
demand constraint,
this is the marginal
revenue gained
by increasing the
demand by one unit.
In this case, the shadow
price is 0 for demand
greater than or equal to 66.
Now, let's look at what happens
when we market regular fares.
If we increase the
demand for regular fares,
our revenue increases.
If we increase by
25 units of demand,
our revenue
increases to $86,883.
If we increase by another
25 units of demand,
our revenue
increases to $96,358.
So what's the shadow
price in this case?
Remember that the
shadow price is
the marginal revenue for
a unit increase in demand,
in this case, of regular seats.
From 100 to 125, the
revenue increased
by $86,883 minus $77,408,
which is equal to $9,475.
Since this was an increase
of 25 units of demand,
the shadow price
is 9,475 divided
by 25, which equals 379.
We can calculate that
this is the same shadow
price from 125 to 150.
So the marginal revenue
for every extra unit
of regular demand from
100 to 166 is $379.
So given this
analysis, how can we
help the marketing department
make their decisions?
The forecast was an extra unit
of demand for every $200 spent.
For discount fares, this isn't
worth it, since the shadow
price, or marginal
revenue, is 0.
But for the regular
fares, this is worth it,
since the shadow price is $379.
So the marketing
department should
invest in marketing
regular fares
to increase the
demand by 66 units.
Another sensitivity analysis
question in our problem
is whether or not it would be
beneficial to allocate a bigger
aircraft for this flight.
This would change the
capacity constraint,
which currently limits
the capacity to 166.
With our current
aircraft, the management
knows that the cost
per hour is $12,067.
So the total cost of the
six-hour flight is $72,402.
With the 166 seats
filled, we get a revenue
of $77,408 from our
optimal solution.
If we increase the capacity
of the aircraft to 176 seats,
the total cost would
increase to $76,590.
But how much would this
increase our revenue?
And if we increase the capacity
of the aircraft to $218,
the total cost would
increase to $87,342.
But how much would this
increase our revenue?
For our analysis, let's assume
that the demand does not
change.
If we increase our
capacity to 176,
the capacity constraint
will move right.
And our optimal solution
will move right too.
We now get a revenue of $79,788.
If we then increase the
capacity to 218 seats,
the capacity constraint
will move right again,
and our revenue will
increase to $89,784.
So let's look at
our extra profit
from increasing the capacity
to see if it's worth it.
With our current costs and
revenue, the profit is $5,006.
If we increase the
capacity to 176 seats,
our profit actually
decreases to $3,198.
And if we increase the
capacity to 218 seats,
our profit decreases
even more to $2,442.
So even though our
revenue is increasing,
the cost increases too.
So it's not profitable
for us to increase
the capacity of our aircraft.
You can also see this by
using LibreOffice, which we'll
ask you to do in the
next quick question.